merci madame la Présidente parce que
t'as demandé je vous demande de
maintenir les régimes spéciaux en
supprimant les régimes spéciaux vous
nier la réalité du port des charges
lourdes vous nier la réalité des
postures pénibles vous nier la réalité
des douleurs persistantes Fournier la
réalité des souffrances au travail vous
n'arrivez pas à faire passer votre
réforme parce que les Français vous
posent seulement une question quand
quand comptez-vous vous attaquez à la
véritable pénibilité au travail quand
comprenez vous taxer les pénible
milliardaires qui profitent des crises
quand comptez-vous attaquer à la pénible
évasion fiscale d'au moins de 80
milliards d'euros par an quand
comptez-vous mettre fin au pénible de
penser l'État en est des entreprises de
157 milliards d'euros quand allez-vous
vous mettre fin au pén des impôts de 16
milliards d'euros en faveur des plus
riches au lieu de pénibilité radissez
nos droits d'un côté vous attaquer à la
création nouveau registre spécial pour
les aides à domicile pour les
aides-soignantes pour les personnes
d'entretien pour les airsh arrêtez cette
pénible aux réforme et attaque vous à la
pénibilité nous serons dans la rue
demain je leur ai dit encore avec le
point levé nous allons vous combattre
merci
cela fait trois jours mes chers
collègues trois jours que nous discutons
de de l'article 1 3 jours que nous
discutons de la suppression des régimes
spéciaux les régimes spéciaux du CESU
les régimes spéciaux de la Banque de
France les régimes spéciaux des clercs
de notaire et dans la défense de vos
amendements vous avez évoqué
les femmes de ménage les ouvriers les
caristes les carreleurs les monteurs
vous les vous les avez évoqués et pour
autant vous frapper à côté mes chers
collègues vous frappez à côté parce que
le système d'aujourd'hui il ne me permet
pas ces gens de partir tôt le système
qui est fait aujourd'hui est totalement
injuste pour eux parce qu'il ne tient
pas en réalité compte de l'exposition à
l'usure professionnelle la parole est à
Madame et merci madame la Présidente et
qu'ils partent à 60 ans ou 62 ans ou
même à 64 ans avec la réforme Touraine
qui je vous le rappelle a été voté en
2014 et qui pour la plupart d'entre eux
partiront à 64 ans et bien le système
aujourd'hui ne permet pas de traiter ces
situations là de pénibilité alors que
l'article 9 et nous souhaitons débattre
de l'article 9 permettra ces personnes
de partir plus tôt permettra à ces
personnes d'avoir une reconversion
professionnelle financée formé pour cela
ou alors un départ anticipé voilà ce que
dit l'article 9 alors s'il vous plaît
vous parler d'obstruction retirer
l'ensemble de vos amendements allons
directement à l'essentiel
occuper
occupons-nous de ces femmes de ménage
occupons-nous de ces caristes de ses
ouvriers en avançant sur le texte voilà
ce que je vous demande mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui et vous n'avez pas
le monopole de ces publics vous n'avez
pas ce monopole vous ne connaissez pas
nos parcours vous ne savez pas qui nous
sommes vous ne savez pas de quels
enfants nous sommes nous les connaissons
ces situations nous les connaissons nous
avons pas besoin d'aller vous merci
Monsieur à votre côté nous les
connaissons alors rentrons dans le vif
du sujet s'il vous plaît merci Madame
la parole est à Madame panot
merci madame la Présidente alors
chers collègues macroniste je vois bien
que vous avez vos petites fiches du
ministère qui arrive pour faire à la
fois de la provocation et de
l'obstruction
s'il y a une obstruction c'est bien
l'obstruction gouvernementale qui a
choisi un véhicule législatif qui nous
oblige à discuter en 9 jours seulement
de ceux qui va changer la vie de
millions de Français et celle des
générations futures et là vous refaites
une obstruction en demandant des
scrutins publiques sur tous nos
amendements que pourtant nos défendons
en faisant croire que nous ne voulions
oui nous sommes fiers d'avoir passé du
temps sur la RATP sur les électriciens
gaziers et je dois dire chers collègues
que votre provocation
que votre provocation tombe complètement
à côté quand vous parlez par exemple des
femmes de ménage en disant vous n'allez
pas le monopole de ces publics comme
vous dites ce qui est extrêmement
méprisant non nous n'avons pas le
monopole de ces personnes comme vous
dites mais nous nous manifestons avec
elle et nous nous avons fait lire Rachel
cake première femme de ménage jamais
élue vous feriez bien de l'écouter parce
que elle elle représente le peuple qui
ne veut pas prendre deux enfers
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
le lundi quand j'ai pris la parole dans
cette musique j'ai demandé qui a déjà
fait des métiers pénibles
vous avez levé la main mais ça ça me
fait plaisir
[Musique]
ce que c'est que faire un métier pénible
mais quand je finis de prendre la parole
et que après derrière vous dites je suis
une comédienne vous montez vous savez
pas ce que c'est que faire un métier
pénible vous mentez à la France parce
que vous savez pas ce que c'est que un
métier pénible
cette réforme de retraite qui écrase les
femmes cette réforme de retraite qui
méprise les femmes cette même réforme
des retraites qui humilient les femmes
je profite pour dire à toutes les femmes
de la France là où elles sont selles
demain quels sont dans la rue
massivement
quels sont dans la rue massivement pour
manifester contre cette forme de
retraite qui les humilie qu'il est
piétine qui les écrase je dis que toutes
les femmes de France toutes les femmes
de ce pays doivent être dans la rue
massivement demain je vous remercie
madame keker rappelle au règlement
madame et allez-y
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
un rappel au réglement titre de
l'article 100 pour la bonne tenue de nos
débats je veux juste vraiment rassurer
madame kéké nous avons énormément de
respect pour votre parcours énormément
de respect par contre madame kéké par
contre
vous vous n'avez pas de respect pour nos
parcours vous n'avez aucun respect pour
nos parcours vous savez pourquoi madame
kéké
madame la députée kéké vous savez
pourquoi parce que vous ne les
connaissez pas parce que vous ne
connaissez pas nos parcours vous ne
connaissez pas le parc je vous remercie
Madame et mais ce n'est pas un rappel au
règlement c'est une interpellation
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est juste pour terminer madame la
Présidente j'appelle toute cette
assemblée à ne pas avoir d'invectives
personnelles
se respecte ici pour ce qu'il est c'est
à dire un représentant de la nation
ça madame panot
merci merci madame la Présidente
je crois que là dans les deux choses qui
ont été pointées je vais d'abord
répondre aux collègues des républicains
avant d'être élu du peuple puisque nous
sommes tous représentants du peuple ici
avant d'être élu du peuple nous sommes
investis par un parti ou une formation
politique et oui je suis fier comment
mouvement politique et investir à
Chelles kéké Caroline Fiat premier
aide-soignante jamais il lui a
l'Assemblée nationale Mathilde gignier
première ouvrière agricole Laura
Alexandre ouvrier de Renault TIC et tant
d'autres et j'aimerais savoir où sont
ces gens qui pour la première fois faut
entendre la voix des 100 voix dans
l'assembler dans votre groupe ou dans
votre groupe madame aille vous dites ça
y est du respect pour nos parcours
c'est vrai que on peut dire que c'est un
parcours un peu différent quand on a
fait 13 ans HSBC ou à la banque Barclays
mais mais la question n'est pas le
respect pour votre parcours la question
c'est l'irrespect que nous avons
absolument total pour la politique que
vous êtes en train de mener vous avez
décidé de mener la guerre contre le
peuple nous ne vous laisserons pas faire
et c'est cela qui est en jeu avec des
gens qui comprennent dans leur chair
dans leur vie ce que veut dire prendre
deux ans de plus de travail avec votre
réforme des retraites à 64 ans et je
vous remercie
rappelle au règlement allez-y
[Applaudissements]
allez-y
rappelle au Règlement sur le fondement
de l'article 70 la bonne tenue des
débats
suppose que nous nous regardions tous
comme représentant de la nation il est
intolérable d'assigner à résidence ceux
qui ont eu à passer professionnel ou une
vie professionnelle différente ici il y
a qu'une catégorie de députés ceux qui
ont été élus par la nation française
tout le reste c'est le rétablissement
des privilèges même des privilèges
inversés
[Applaudissements]